it feels like there's this whole other
movie over here and this dis Jackie Chan
thing yeah it's weird because I feel
like Jackie Chan's story would have been
more effective if they treated his story
from the beginning like the main
supporting story like the main B story
yeah then you walk away going Jackie
Chan's really the scene stealer then you
all got us going really just because of
the pitch in the title Wow hello reject
nation I'm Greg helva and I'm Joan um
free so we're gonna talk about a movie
today the foreigner by the foreigner
we're doing an Irish accent because it's
really not about a [ __ ] yeah well
that was a book I don't look title was
the book title they say Jason yeah okay
so we're just quoting the movie there
we're not actually racist against the
Chinese people want to make that clear
so before going into this film I was
pretty excited for because I grew up a
huge Jackie Chan fanatic yeah we were
young kids really into Jackie Chan
watch from along the Bronx when I was a
kid and then I watched much of his Hong
Kong films and over the past few years
in terms of American cinema shower three
he hasn't been all too appealing to the
world lately Tracy yeah one of the films
are really enjoyed that he did a few
years ago was the Karate Kid actually
and I thought he gave a wonderful
dramatic performance in it so I've kind
of been hoping he'd transition a little
bit more into that arena into being a
strong dramatic actor of one of those
like old man action heroes I mean he's
in the phrase old man Chan lately by the
time this movie was done you realize
this movie's more of an IRA political
thriller this is not about Jesus not
that what the trailers like what's in
the trailer is in the movie but that's
not what you walk away from by the time
it's all done most of the emotional and
intense focus of the film is actually
dedicated to what's going on with Pierce
Brosnan as this Irish government person
who works with the British government
was to watch Jackie Chan carry out his
mission you have to watch it completely
others yeah about Pierce Bryce
inner-workings IRA terrorist attack and
government stuff and yeah
because what the trailer sets it up as
and it is the setup of the film Jackie
Chan has a daughter they live in England
and then there's a bombing that goes off
and Jackie Chan believes pierce brosnan
knows the people who are responsible for
this so he's kind of sitting on this
vengeance mission just to find out the
names of the people so he can extract
revenge on those specific bombers but
halfway through the film you realize
most of the camera time is actually sped
towards Pierce Brosnan and all the
political thriller stuff which is very
intriguing and really gripping stuff but
it is not the movie it's not an old man
chant kicking ass Jackie Chan sets off
on his mission his first you know point
of contact is alright I got to talk to
pierce brosnan he sees them on TV or
whatever and then once the movie gets
there it's like I guess we got to learn
who this guy is yeah and then the whole
rest of the movie is kind of about cuz
it starts off with like I like that
we're gonna you know Pierce Brosnan
that's cool yeah it's like this movie's
taking time for all of the different
characters in the in the situation it's
not long after we're like whenever
Jackie Chan shows up you're like yeah
your movie time you're watching a very
compelling and you know suspenseful and
cathartic even at times you like you
said IRA it's really every 20 minutes or
so Jackie Chan pops back up to you know
mess some things that something and then
go tell me the names you would tell me
the names of the Bombers the first
half-hour he was a great performance
he's the central focus of the like the
first 30 to 40 minutes of this film it's
done in a clever way because as the
audience who's aware of Jackie Chan
especially with the trailers being like
the legend returns you're expecting like
old man Chan kicking ass suspecting
Death Wish with J yeah it doesn't just
hop straight into he's like destroying
[ __ ] it's escalating yeah what to the
point where it takes so much time
developing who this guy is that you
forget that Jackie Chan knows how to do
a bunch of martial art yes maíam as this
old guy and I was thinking this is
really brilliant this is clever
cuz I am totally buying into this old
Asian dude who's grieving right now and
I'm not aware at all that this is a
martial arts legendary actor right here
yeah yeah totally that was something I
was actually worried about going into
this movie one of the things I wasn't as
optimistic about the trailer and part of
that was I was wondering about his
character cuz I was like
the point of this movie like Tara's
killed my daughter so I got to becoming
terrorist and yet a lot of people and
you know just every scene in that
trailer shows that same kind of empty
look and I'm like okay he looks
depressed but when the movie like sets
out it takes its time and in taking its
time you start to feel alright I guess
this guy's got no other choice than to
take matters into my own hands if he
can't let go of it and yeah it gripped
me the way a film would not the way
taken starring Jackie Chan would yeah
and that was a surprise to me and yeah
I'm really like there's a lot of people
said like this it looks like taking with
Jackie Chan but it's not that at all
yeah it really isn't that movie at all
by the end of the film not even by the
end about halfway through the film it
really hit me this is way more Pierce
Brosnan's maybe Jackie Chan becomes the
subplot yeah he's like the B story who
kind of just interferes with this story
Reaper of the IO that's one of the
fascinating experiences of this film by
the time the movie was done I was
thinking to myself I really heavily
appreciated how this film was much more
than yeah this guy taking revenge and
you know Pierce Brosnan being like bad
guy who yells at his henchmen to yah why
can't you take out old guy good
politician no easy yeah there's so much
more than that yeah Pierce Brosnan's
characters so multi-layered and
surrounded by other multi-layered
characters and the political mystery and
intrigue is very well done the thing
though that happens is is you realize
this all kind of overshadows the entire
effect of what Jackie Chan story is in
the movie cuz his is the only one that's
not like do like it's removed from
everything else yeah and that's why this
does feel like two movies crashed into
cuz by the time everything's unfolded
you kind of like tower in the car ride
back going what purpose did Jackie Chan
serve and the bigger story of this
exactly and then we were able to do
without spoiling anything like we were
able to come up with conclude as well he
did this yeah he did that but it's one
of those things where you have to go
like well maybe because he interfered
here and it caused this political plot
it happened that's the main purpose he
served there's a lot of interplay and
some of the effects Jackie Chan has on
the plot and changed the outcome of
certain other situations you've seen and
so yeah by the end when you've done all
the movie math at the end your life you
kind of remove
two in the same problems would occurred
for Pierre and the same outcome probably
would it would have happened in the end
actually these just now it's got an
extra facet because what the trailer
doesn't show you is that this is really
an IRA political thriller and then you
also got British intelligence in on this
mission to look for the Bombers and
there's a lot of focus given to the
British intelligence as well there's so
much else happening the most intense
gripping of emotional dramatic scenes
are with Pierce Brosnan's here yeah yeah
because he's got the most likes takes
all the time cuz he's the one trying to
keep everything yeah yeah there's
someone with the most secrets is even
when you're watching Jackie Chan entire
movie you're like he's got this like I
know he's gotta make it to the end of
this movie and he's gonna do something
yeah crazy so I'm not really concerned I
am concerned piers bras because it's
like the weird thing about this film is
both houses are cool they're both really
good movies it's just the second movie
when it shifts into that overshadows the
effect of the first movie that you
showed up for yeah you know cuz it
because about that second half it's a
different movie than you want it yeah
it's definitely a different movie than
you were pitched yeah and it's weird to
me because I feel like taken with Jackie
Chan might have done more for Jackie
Chan's career than this movie yeah cuz
the thing about this is we just saw this
so I'm still kind of mulling over how
his part complements the rest of the
movie but it is sort of like the thing
you're talking about are thinking about
the most for me when I left the movie is
not necessarily the Jackie Chan stuff
cuz I keep coming up with this
conclusion of like it feels like there's
this whole other movie over here and
this dis check your chances yeah it
really just because of the pitch in the
title of the film Agnes misleads you
down this map is called the [ __ ] too
so I know that there I assume at least
there must be you know a lot of
significance to why we sent her around
Jackie Chan because he is the only
person I guess kinda like us even though
his backstory comes up he's clearly not
yeah he's gotta be significant but it
does sort of leave you at least from for
the both of us kind of scratching your
head a little bit it felt like the
screenwriting the director they cared a
lot to flesh out Chan's character yeah
and especially in the first half but I
feel like the story they really wanted
to tell was the IRA political thriller
that's the situation at hand yeah and
Jackie Chan's story is so simple yeah he
almost becomes a part of just a bigger
story he's just another thorn in a
series of thorns
imperio yes so I don't feel like you're
walk away from this film being like this
is Jackie Chan's movie this really is a
really good film it's just not the film
you're hoping to get and you got to have
some understanding of IRA history like
23 minutes in the film I have to look
over you and be like wait a minute I'm
forgetting some IRA history because
they're not they're not laying this out
for an audience member like myself and I
feel bad for all the people that are
gonna go into this wanting to see an
action movie with Jackie Chan because
you get some cool action scenes in here
but you don't really walk away thinking
about the cool action scenes well yeah
and it's also not that kind of action
movie yeah it's like there are some
great it's more like a Bourne style
movie than the Bond style movie I guess
because the action is pretty and it's
not cool yeah stuff it's not like
awesome and it's cool for a champ Jackie
Chan found like myself to see Jackie
Chan embracing this kind of action yeah
because it is more of a realistic type
of fighting no funny stuff happens in
the fight scenes but he does use a lot
of props see he still grabs things in
the room yeah he's still grabbed but
it's more of a like the gritty version
of Jackie Chan yeah it's the born Bert
yeah exactly
born version yeah i feel like in there
Jackie Chan movies he uses way more
props and sometimes it's kind of funny
in the way he uses it I don't walk away
from this associating it with fight
scenes which is which is sort of I guess
going back a compliment to it but also
the tracks from from what you wanted
yeah I guess that's what I meant by the
whole like I don't know how much this
movie's gonna do for Jackie Chan cuz
like yeah all his parts of it yeah are
kind of overshadowed by a much bigger
movie yeah I mean like don't get me
wrong Jackie Chan's great it's just by
the end of the film you realize I was
way more invested in the political
thriller like everything is good as I
was surprised and it's it's still
apparent - yeah good this is different
that I got I got to give the credit to
the film for being more than another
taken movie then because this could have
been a simple vengeance movie but they
did a lot more with it yeah yeah right I
was really good I'm just saying you
don't be completely going into this film
thinking this is what I'm gonna go see
ya like that hook is not the rest of it
yeah it's like the first half of the
movie the last app is like way more
political yeah
and then Jackie Chan shows up every once
in a while to say give me the names yeah
it's like once he decides to go on the
mission the rest of his characters just
give me the names no I'm gonna make
things hard for you yeah all right you
know cuz that stuff doesn't really
develop into something more and more
Jackie Chan's character sorters waiting
around for the entire other he needs the
information that the rest of the plot
the characters in the movie need you
know we need so it makes sense that we
would have to wait to see him show up
and so I'd say like yeah if you want to
see a more dramatic take of Jackie Chan
go for it and if you want to see a great
price jacket yeah go see it I feel like
even if it was a even if I didn't see
the trailers I still would have been
like well the first the second half of
this movie kind of over casts a lot of
the things from the first half so I
would give it like a three and a half
out of five stars maybe four at four I
would give this a four because because
it surprised me and the stuff that
surprised me with I was like oh this is
great you know it's intense its intense
yeah yeah yeah so I you know knock off
that extra star for not as much Jackie
all right reject nation well that's our
review of the foreigner let me ask you
guys question what's your favorite
Jackie Chan movie or your favorite
Pierce Brosnan movie it's probably gonna
be a Bond movie subscribe to the reel
rejects please click that notification
bail because subscribe buttons are
broken that's John Humphrey on Twitter
and Instagram follow him there you can
follow us at the Stardust app at the
real rejects go over there and follow us
follow us really jex follow us follow us
follow us follow us everywhere be it our
house